bonsoir aujourd'hui 10 juin 2015
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction le point sur l'actualité
locale voici quelques-uns des titres que
nous allons à développer au cours de la
prochaine demi heure le syndicat des
patrons le medef organise régulièrement
des rendez vous thématiques pour ses
adhérents
hier soir pour parler du passage de la
tp au groupe international franck
provost était notamment très bien roulé
sur la piste du vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
dorénavant possible des baptêmes sont
proposés encadrés par des professionnels
nous l'avons testé pour vous et puis ya
donc deux jours à peine va s'ouvrir la
quatrième édition de paroles de
jardinier dans le département un rendez
vous pour les passionnés de jardinage
amateurs et professionnels invités ce
soir alain baraton jardinier-en-chef du
château de versailles parrain de cet
événement cette information pour débuter
depuis le 31 mai la police recherche
cette jeune fille de est de 17 ans
portée disparue depuis qu'elle a quitté
son domicile d alu et le roi dans les
yvelines en fin de journée vers 18
heures elle est vêtue d'un legging noir
d'un manteau noir et de chaussures
orange elle mesure 1 m 75
elle aurait déjà fugué une vingtaine de
fois selon une source proche de
l'enquêté
vous pouvez contacter la gendarmerie
dans le val si vous disposez est
d'éléments ou composez le 17
on bosse ici est ensemble on fait le
même travail on veut les même droits
c'est le message que vous avez pu voir
aujourd'hui sur est des pancartes si
vous êtes passés dans le quartier de la
gare de saint-quentin
une soixantaine de travailleurs sans
papiers ont investi les locaux de l'
agence d'intérim adecco opération coup
de poing pour ses travailleurs syndiqués
cgt qui dénonce les abus de leur
employeur en france des milliers de
salariés de l'intérim et même des salles
ali qui travaillent pendant l'intérim
sont exploités du fait qu'ils soient
sans papiers c'est sa salariée là on ne
respecte pas leurs droits ni comment
sont collectives ne sont pas respectées
les cinq salariés l'ont pas les heures
supplémentaires de rémunérer ils ont
même des journées qui ne sont pas
réunies à rémunérer à des cures refusent
souvent de remplir les cerfa pour puisse
faire pour que les salariés puissent
faire une demande
régularisation et avoir des papiers
comme tout le monde monte des
négociations vont déjà avec la déco mais
aussi avec le patronat de l'intérim pour
qu'ils puissent avoir à l'union
nationale des bases saines pour ses
salariés là puissent être régularisés et
que leurs droits soient respectés
nos revendications sont claires c'est
obtenir auprès des patrons ce qu'il veut
ce qu'il nous faut les attestations de
contrôle dans le certificat de décès
fort remplie par eux parce qu'on
travaille ici haut et on cotise au taux
obtenu aussi auprès de la préfecture
le récépissé qui permettront de nous
autoriser à travailler au moment où
elles remplissent les critères
au même moment une autre action a eu
lieu dans un autre compte des yvelines
aux mureaux une opération qui va durer à
toute la nuit et qui continuera demain
jeudi
économie de l'atp au groupe
international c'était la thématique
proposée hier soir par le medef des
yvelines à l'occasion de leur assemblée
générale de chef d'entreprise franck
provost et sébastien vercruysse sont
venus apporter leur témoignage écouter
des chefs d'entreprise qui ont réussi
quoi de mieux pour booster le moral des
patrons ils étaient les invités du medef
des yvelines
franck provost créateur des salons de
coiffure qui porte son nom et sébastien
vercruysse livigno est intégrateur de
solutions informatiques pour les pme pmi
aujourd'hui à la tête d'une entreprise
de 100 salariés
lancée en 2002 dans la pépinière de
montigny-le-bretonneux
on est tous des commerçants et donc qui
dit commerçant dit dit est très proche
très proche de ses clients
le deuxième point c'est l'innovation
c'est quelque chose qui concerne chaque
entreprise un boulanger peut innover un
assureur peut innover et l'innovation
c'est cette capacité que doit à mon avis
avoir un entrepreneur de se remettre en
question de remettre en question son
marché font provost on ne le présente
plus la ouvert son premier salon de
coiffure dans les yvelines à saint
germain en laye il ya 40 ans c'est
capital de savoir s'entourer de deux
bonnes équipes des personnes qui qui qui
ont vraiment là la passion la même
passion qu'ils partagent la même passion
de l'entreprise et d'avoir une confiance
et puis surtout tout passe par la
formation surtout dans nos métiers quoi
donc il est important de former des
personnes qui soit professionnellement
au point des conseils utiles pour les
chefs d'entreprise présents lors de
l'assemblée générale du medef des
yvelines l'occasion aussi pour le
mouvement des patrons d'annoncer la
naissance de la commission financement
des entreprises
le fruit d'un travail de deux ans qui
doit servir à accompagner les sociétés
dans leur recherche de solutions
aujourd'hui on a on a un joli process
c'est qu'on puisse développer le
partager avec d'autres organisations été
complice sur tout et des autres pays à
se développer
le medef des yvelines compte 200
entreprises adhérentes et 80 % ont moins
de 50 salariés
la quatrième édition de paroles de
jardiniers débutants à 48 heures du 13
au 28 juin trois week-ends de partage
ateliers spectacles à travers le
département c'est en tout cas la
promesse le parrain de cet événement
depuis le début c'est alain baraton
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau jardinier en chef du domaine
national à du trianon du grand parc du
château de versailles un rendez vous
pour les passionnés et pour les curieux
amateurs professionnels et ils sont
nombreux
j'ai l'immense bonheur l'immense
privilège d'être le parrain de
l'occasion de présenter un domaine que
j'aime bien versé de parler également
avec tous ceux qui consacrent leurs
loisirs au jardin ils sont donc de plus
en plus nombreux car il est vrai que le
jardin a souvent été un petit peu mis de
côté le jardin est un peu ce vieil homme
ou cette vieille dame un peu oisive à la
retraite qui s'extasiaient devant la
poussée des tomates pour la
fructification d'inscrits mais c'est
autre chose c'est aussi une philosophie
je suis très heureux de constater que
parole de jeanne et donne la parole aux
jardiniers
permettra surtout à des centaines de
propriétaires et d'amateurs de montrer
d'ouvrir leur jardin et de faire
découvrir des merveilles
il ya 63 jardin qui vont ouvrir leurs
portes l'occasion pour chacun de prendre
des conseils de s'approprier aussi des
techniques
le jardinier c'est ça aussi il faut
s'enrichir de ce que fait l'autre oui
j'ai connu l'époque où les anciens
garder jalousement leurs secrets
aujourd'hui forte heureusement tout cela
n'est que du passé
l'intérêt de cette manifestation c'est
justement de mettre en relation les
jeunes et les moins jeunes les âmes et
les femmes les professionnels et les
amateurs et que l'on échange que l'on
communique en un mot que l'on donne
envie à l'autre soit d'apprendre soit de
s'améliorer ce sont notamment des
jardins familiaux aussi qui seront
ouverts les jardins partagés par exemple
la voisins bretons ne les jardins
familiaux à guyancourt vous êtes surpris
quelques fois de ce que réalise mais les
amateurs très éclairés on va dire tout
de même oui comme vous le savez je viens
dans un domaine prestigieux les jardins
sont connus dans le monde entier et j'ai
connu à une époque de 2,2 de mon
existence des moments d'autosatisfaction
mois de versailles je ne peux plus être
surpris
grave erreur on découvre dans certaines
propriétés et dans les yvelines en
particulier des jardins sublime fait
avec un goût inouïe par des gens qui
disposent de peu de moyens simplement il
avait du temps il avait de l'amour
il avait de l'imagination donc ce n'est
pas une question d'histoire du lieu ce
n'est pas une question d'argent c'est
simplement une question de créativité et
dans vie de faire plaisir car c'est ça
je crois le principe même du jardin
faire se faire plaisir et faire plaisir
à ses proches
jardiner c'est un loisir qui se
développe de plus en plus et ça ne coûte
pas nécessairement cher c'est ce que
vous nous dites jardiner c'est un
plaisir qu'il ça monte très vite il ya
bien sûr un petit matériel de base à ce
concurrent
mais quand on regarde le
l'investissement cantoria bhl le rapport
le profit et quand on regarde surtout la
joie que cela offre
je rappelle que dans le jardin tout le
monde peut participer les jeunes et les
moins jeunes les personnes âgées les
amis donc c'est un plaisir collectif qui
finalement est bien on s'aime ce que
l'on rit on récolte ce que l'on sème
non content d'avoir deux d'avoir investi
un petit peu de sou vrai col t des
légumes parfois des fruits vous faites
des bouquets de fleurs et vous mettez de
la couleur dans votre paysage avoue que
ça n'a pas de prix
des giardini en 1976 pour château de
versailles vous êtes depuis 1982
jardinier en chef est ce que vous
apprenez encore aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
on apprend tous les jours
et justement l'intérêt de parole de
jardiniers c'est de mettre en relation
des gens qui ont beaucoup d'expérience
avec d'autres qui en ont moins
et je suis persuadé dimanche quand je
vais ouvrir les portes des serres à des
centaines de visiteurs que certains vont
me faire part de trucs et astuces qui au
début vont peut-être me faire tiquer
mais discrètement dans leur dos je
vérifierai moi même sur le terrain je
vais dire le bien fondé de leurs
affirmations et souvent on a des
surprises
donc oui j'ai encore beaucoup à
apprendre c'est il ya un homme que nous
a quittés cette semaine à qui j'en rends
hommage michel lis ce qui fut la grande
voix de france inter en termes de jardin
il a été le genre le janvier préféré des
français
eh bien il est décédé à 78 ans il me
disait il ya peu encore qu ils continuer
d'apprendre le programme complet de la
manifestation parole de jardiniers point
fr vous aurez à toutes les animations
qui sont proposées pour les trois
semaines à venir y ait une thématique
cette année la thématique selo forcément
l'eau d'importance primordiale pour le
jardin pas d'eau pas de jardin veille
comment gérer l'eau d'où vient l'eau
comment circulent tel dans la terre
comment l'utiliser existe-t-il une mais
des méthodes pour l'économiser faut-il
beaucoup arrosé ou moins arrosé
il ya beaucoup de questions que l'on se
pose sur l'eau ce sera justement
l'occasion doigt lors de cette
manifestation d'avoir enfin les vraies
réponses aux vraies questions et parce
qu'on parle souvent d'économiser l'eau
denrée rare on peut jardiner sans en
faisant attention simplement en arrosant
le soir plus tôt dans la journée
simplement en arrosant les plantes qui
seulement n'ont besoin
comment faire pour constater qu'une
plante a vraiment besoin d'eau d'éviter
le gaspillage récolter l'eau de pluie
elle est souvent abondantes souvent dans
notre région et elle est gratuite
donc il ya quantité de choses à
apprendre sur l'eau et là encore une
fois qu'on a maîtrisé
l'utilisation d'eau et sa captation élus
on transmettra aux générations futures
comment faire on peut citer ce rendez
vous dans le cadre de cette
manifestation histoire d'eau dimanche 14
juin
temps fort puisque c'est l'ouverture
avec vous parrain de l'événement il y
aura une conférence comment ça va
s'organiser salle aura à verser wyss
avait traversé je vais conversé pendant
une petite heure avec les personnes qui
se sont inscrites puis j'ai demandé à
trois de mes collaborateurs jeunes et
brillants de ma 6t pour rencontrer les
visiteurs converser avec eux et après
partir dans les gens là pour une petite
promenade bucolique
non pour être tout à fait précis il y
aura aussi une autre manifestation un
bassin au jardin ce sera à coignières je
vous disais toutes les communes du
département qui s'associent de plus en
plus de communes veulent y participer
d'ailleurs c'est satisfaction tant que
parent c'est un homme et c'est
encourageant ça prouve que le jardin est
aujourd'hui devenu une nécessité et que
les citadins ont besoin de nature ils
ont besoin de chlorophylle ils ont
besoin des espaces verts il y aura une
grande fête le 28 ans va pas décliné
tout le programme mais on peut
s'attarder sur cet événement puisque là
ce sera à saint germain en laye parle
souvent là du domaine de versailles mais
aussi saint germain domaine remarquable
vous y serez présent oui ça ce que ça
jean noël est un très très joli jardin
avec une vue époustouflante sur paris et
sa région une terrasse sublime voulue
par andré le nôtre
il n'y a pas que le versailles comme
jardin sublime il ya la quantité
d'autres des domaines nationaux mais
aussi vous le disiez tout à l'heure des
jardins privés y aura donc cette
manifestation le 28 par le jardinier
point fr pour tout savoir en tout 260
deux manifestations animations donc
département des yvelines
c'est de plus en plus au fur à mesure
des différentes éditions vous avez
constaté un engouement de plus en plus
fort pour le jardinage dans son ensemble
ces dernières années il y a toujours eu
de l'engouement pour le jardinage je
constate simplement que l'âge de ceux
qui se prennent de passion pour cette
pour ce loisir sont de plus en plus
jeunes lorsque je rencontrais des
amateurs il y à quoi des soupes 15 ans
la majorité était à la retraite
aujourd'hui on peut dire que les 30-40
ans sont devenus importants en un mot
quand on assiste à une conférence sur le
jardin on peut se dire que finalement la
population représente à peu près ce
qu'elle au niveau national il ya des
jeunes et des moins jeunes des actifs et
des retraités il ya des brouilles à des
moches les hommes il ya les vins il ya
de tout le monde du jardin est devenu
dans la pratique
l'image de ce qu'est la société
française ça veut dire quoi qu'il ya un
retour à la terre on a besoin d' espaces
verts aussi au milieu de ses cadres
urbains se veut dire qu'il ya encore dix
ou quinze ans il était beau de bon chic
de rentrer chez soi avec les doigts
manucurés et qu'aujourd'hui quand on
arrivait que les doigts pleins de terre
et une botte de poireaux justement qui
dégouline eh bien il n'y a plus de honte
au contraire on est fier de montrer sa
récolte parler des poireaux justement
vous avez décidé je profitais de votre
présence ici de remettre en culture le
jardin des arènes
oui on exalte est un petit peu les
différentes saveurs des légumes et
fruits de ce potager qui ont et qui a
été abandonné 7 et l'an dernier
la récolte n ya pas tellement longtemps
elle fut abondante et de qualité en
particulier nos arguments propres
produits d'aidé bonnotte de noirmoutier
l'idée est simplement de rappeler que
sans le jardinier le cuisinier
n'existerait pas et j'ai voulu montrer
qu'il était possible de fournir des
légumes de qualité sans mettre une
goutte de produit chimique et pour
choisir le chef nous avons opté pour
alain ducasse ce n'est quand même pas
rien et nous avons un partenariat
d'excellence avec ce grand chef
cuisinier pour le restaurant du plaza
athénée où il fournit sont des légumes
produits dans le potager de la reine lui
même les met en scène je dirais les met
en spectacle dans ses cuisines le
résultat est époustouflant et je suis
heureux de voir que cette nouvelle
génération de journée qu'ils cultivent
finalement entre guillemets que des
légumes
aujourd'hui côtoie les plus grands chefs
cuisiniers du monde ça me fait plaisir
c'est ce que j'appelle la revalorisation
de ce métier merveilleux qu'est le
jardinier alain ducasse qui était
l'invité sur téléfilm 78 il y a quelques
jours devait y paie je vous propose en
écouter un extrait y parle justement de
cette collaboration
oui sur le potager récent la suite j'ai
une passion pour la première de leur
métier depuis longtemps donc c'est pas
nouveau
tiens on va à la plante et parce que cet
été et redouane miloudi la terre est
extraordinaire mais c'est vrai qu'à nous
en aiguille avec ça ordinaire c'est bien
calé elle n'est pas sûre solliciter les
animaux en dessous font leur travail
il n'y a pas de pesticides n'y a pas de
traitement il n'ya pas dormir avec un
syndicat c'est une complicité qui s'est
installée à une réelle complicité la
même passion pour le pour le bien-être
pour le bonheur et pour une nature
généreuse comme le disait alain ducasse
pas de pesticides pas d'engrais
chimiques pas de désherbant chimique
rien de l'eau du terreau des graines et
beaucoup d'amour et le résultat
aujourd'hui est à la hauteur de nos
attentes car je vous assure que produire
des légumes comme les petits pois des
tomates des salades ou encore des navets
qui se retrouvent cuisiné par les plus
grands chefs du monde
je rappelle que ducasse le cuisinier le
plus étoilé sur la planète
et bien c'est une fierté que nous avons
c'est un partenariat d'excellence qui
rend plus rapportent quelques deniers à
d'établissement public ça ne coûte rien
au château je ne peux que m'en féliciter
cuisiner jardiner salabert oui moi je ne
cuisine pas je ne sais pas s'avérer
vainement par contre je mange
gg à coups de fourche est redoutable et
je suis un contemplatif j'aime regarder
un plat avant de le savourer jeu
rock que je n'ai pas pu affûter vous
contempler aussi les différents un
jardin lors de cette manifestation ce
sera à vous d'y participer d'ouvrir au
jardin ou tout simplement de venir y
prendre quelques renseignements
pratiques parole de jardinier à partir
de ce week end et pour trois semaines
dans tout le département des yvelines
merci bien c'est sur ce plateau nous
parlons à présent de sport avec les très
bons résultats de l'équipe de france
lors des championnats du monde qui ont
lieu au vélodrome en février dernier qui
ont sans doute donner quelques envies à
certains quand on voit la piste pourtant
pas toujours facile de se lancer et pour
et fait face est en tout cas atténuer
cette appréhension vous pouvez
dorénavant vous initier avec les membres
de l'équipe de france mélanie poker tout
est une question d'anticipation
on peut pas s'arrêter en moins de deux
ans freinant super fort il faut coach de
luxe pour ces cyclistes quentin lafargue
médaillé de bronze en vitesse
individuelle lors des derniers
championnats du monde est là pour guider
leurs premiers tours de piste ce qui m'a
attiré c'est le fait de pouvoir essayer
de transmettre un petit peu et puis
rentrer en contact avec d'autres gens ce
que c'est vrai qu'ici on a une super
structure
mais les limites de tout ça c'est qu'on
est d'emmener en vase clos on est
toujours 24 sur 24 avec des cyclistes
est souvent les mêmes têtes puisque aux
policiers on est on est 13 ans connaît
tellement ce conte ce qu'on fait tous
les jours que
moi j'aime bien faire ça difficile après
c'est sûr que on n'a pas forcément les
mots facile au début c'est à dire qu'on
n'emploie peut-être d'un vocabulaire un
peu technique dans un premier temps mais
au fur et à mesure on arrive à faire en
sorte que tout le monde comprenne
sur les 300 abonnés que compte
aujourd'hui le vélodrome sans ont
découvert la piste grâce au baptême ont
en effet monté progressivement on l'a
seulement après sur la piste en effet
montré que dans les lignes droites les
gens ont envie ont vraiment envie de
revenir dans le parce que ce n'est pas
la finalité ce n'est pas que le baptême
à finalité c'est de faire venir des gens
dans les débutants après les
intermédiaires et des confirmés
s'adapter au pignon fixe aux pédales
automatiques quelques tours de réglages
dans la roue d'un médaillé et les
progrès sont déjà là je trouve que c'est
quand on suit bien les conseils c'est
assez simple j'avais plus peur que ça
mais je pense à face et c'est vraiment
bien mais franchement c'est génial
sensation de vitesse sensation d'être en
extérieur c'est rigolo de la sensation
d'être pris au vent ça c'est l'état
vision de voir le plancher qui tourne un
petit peu l'impression d'être en pointe
sur la piste depuis son inauguration en
janvier 2014 le vélodrome a accueilli
4312 baptême alors à quand le vôtre on
connaît les interventions des pompiers
sur les incendies les accidents de la
route ou encore les secours d'urgence à
la personne mais les pompiers sont
parfois amenés à intervenir dans des
zones dites périlleuse c'est à cette
occasion qui est appelé plus
spécifiquement le groupe c'est un groupe
de reconnaissance et d'intervention en
milieu périlleux ce week-end de
nombreuses casernes avaient ouvert leurs
portes nous sommes rendus à celle de
bois d'arcy saint cyr l'école méningaud
quai et william l
il s'apprête à monter à 42 mètres de
hauteur une distance presque banal pour
eux ces sapeurs pompiers font partie du
grain de 78 le groupe de reconnaissance
et d'intervention en milieu périlleux
des yvelines comme tous sapeurs pompiers
on a un tronc commun de formation qui
est notre quotidien donc secours à
personne
intervention incendie secours routier
opérations diverses
et lorsqu'une opération un peu
spécifique a lieu et qu'on requiert le
grimp
les gens quittent leurs fonctions
opérationnelles classique et rejoint les
lieux de l'intervention pour pour faire
latter l'intervention et mpm qu'elle
reste là où tel sur le département ils
sont 37 sapeurs pompiers opérationnel et
interviennent vingt à vingt-cinq fois
par an un chiffre très éloigné des 3300
interventions du centre de bois d'arcy
saint cyr l'école mais qu'il est due à
la rareté des situations nos missions
sont des missions de reconnaissance et
de sauvetage en milieu périlleux donc
évacuations de personnes en difficulté
sur des châteaux d'eau par exemple ou
des grues et notre
notre utilisation plutôt principal c'est
l'appui au brancardage pour les gens du
samu sur des personnes qui devait
évacuer allongé une démonstration
d'intervention fait devant un public
impressionné qui a pu se mettre un
instant dans la peau d'un sapeur-pompier
des avantages leurs deux petites filles
qui adorent c'est l'aja 4 on l adore les
pompiers qui voulaient voir leurs petits
jouets en grandeur nature donc le camion
derrière qu'elles ont tout petit et
l'ont vu en grand et là c'était du
bonheur dans leurs yeux
ah oui c'est tout à fait impressionnant
oui tout à fait impressionnant oui vu la
hauteur et
non vraiment oui ils sont très
courageuse et huit sauveteurs sont
actuellement en cours de formation dans
les yvelines tout autre sujet à présent
disco soupe c'est un mouvement solidaire
festif qui s'approprie l espace public
pour sensibiliser au gaspillage
alimentaire l'un des derniers rendez
vous vient de se tenir dans le cadre
d'alternatiba c'était à la verrière
toutes les explications avec sephora
famille des blettes des courgettes et
des tomates grillé à la plancha des
assiettes aussi savoureuse que coloré
c'est ce que vous pouviez goûter samedi
dernier place du marché lors de la
discussion organisée par la mairie de
guyancourt en partenariat avec
l'association migraines et c'est vrai
que c'est très très bon y'a j'essaye de
depuis tout à l'heure de vol et les
secrets de fabrication
il ya plein d'idées très fantastique
très très intéressant pour ça va au
moins comme on pourrait pas se
débarrasser des trucs qu'on peu l'usure
utiliser douzième fois celui rejeté à la
poubelle pour tout l'aspect bac
conviviale
de la manifestation discuter avec les
gens partager des recettes aussi ne plus
jeter ses restes mais les accommoder
grâce à des hausses est ingénieuse
partagé par les participants sur l'arbre
recettes des restes constitue l'un des
bons gestes à adopter pour ne plus
gaspiller les bons gestes pour éviter de
faire ses courses quand on a faim déjà
ça peut être pas mal parce qu'on n'est
pas tentée par par tout ce qu'il ya
faire une lève une liste de courses ça
peut être aussi une manière de prévoir
ses achats en ayant bien vérifier ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a dans le frigo au
préalable par acheter des choses qui par
exemple 300 kg de fruits et légumes
invendus ont été collectées auprès des
commerçants le matin même de la disco
souple ils ont ensuite été triés lavés
et cuisiner afin d'être dégustés 300 kg
qui s'il n'avait pas été récupérées
aurait pu partir à la poubelle
il ya beaucoup de gaspillage alimentaire
chaque français jette entre 20 et 30 kg
de d'aliments encore comestibles
chaque année en france on alors
évidemment la production la distribution
sont aussi des ddd moment des phases où
il ya beaucoup de gaspillage
mais le comportement de nous tous est
aussi très responsable de ce gaspillage
sensibiliser au gaspillage alimentaire
avec les disques ou sous fait partie du
dispositif de la programmation liée au
développement durable que propose la
ville de guyancourt tout au long de
l'année
nous repartons à versailles où la ville
a inauguré il ya quelques instants
aujourd'hui non sans émotion un square
au nom de jonathan sandler rue solférino
ce professeur de 30 ans d'origine juive
a été assassiné par mohamed merah le 19
mars 2012 devant l'école ozar hatorah de
toulouse avec ses deux fils
arie et gabriel c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve qui a
présidé la cérémonie un sens de ma
présence et le sens du devoir de mémoire
doit d'être là pour
dire qu'on n'oublie pas le martyre de
ceux qui sont tombés sous le feu de
barbe à dire aussi que la république est
plus forte que certaines rappeler ce que
sont les valeurs de la république
rappelé l'attachement qui est le nôtre à
faire en sorte que l'antisémitisme n'est
aucune place dans la société française
parce que l'antisémitisme c'est le
contraire de la république c'est pour
moi l'occasion de dire une émotion de
dire une fermeté républicaine une
détermination à protéger tous les
français et notamment les français de
confession juive qui sont victimes de
l'antisémitisme
parce que la république lorsque
l'essentiel est en jeu
on n'appelle aucune concession à ses
principes elle doit être ferme et
déterminée j'étais très touché par par
la présence d'un moulin d'intérieur du
président du sénat et surtout enquêter
et 7 ce square qui va rester le nom va
rester parce que je suis très sensible à
la mémoire comme je les dis on se
souvient toujours de nom les assassins
jamais des victimes
et là au moins un an +6 dans un milieu
scolaire
mon fils voulait quitter sa vocation
d'enseigner donc en plus à versailles
est une ville qu'il aimait donc il a été
scout à versailles il a été l'élève de
marcel tassencourt donc s'il pouvait pas
mieux tomber et on marche de cette
inauguration bernard cazeneuve le
ministre de l'intérieur a confirmé
aujourd'hui le déblocage par l'état à
200000 euros pour démarrer les études de
faisabilité est du nouveau commissariat
d'elancourt benoît hamon député
socialiste de la 11e circonscription dit
avoir obtenu est la garantie de la
disponibilité immédiate de ces
différents crédits et dans un instant
sur tv fils kiosques le magazine de la
culture présentait préparé par catherine
mulato rendez vous demain pour un
nouveau journal aux horaires habituels
18 heures pour la première édition en
direct belle soirée